here we go again against Yardbird Eric
LeBron current score in our match is
minus three for me 12 wins 15 losses
five draws check 32 games total ok we
have a Queen's Indian an opening that I
to be honest absolutely don't know I
normally play the ninja with white and
not the not this so I'm kind of making
things up here as we go along I'd like
to study this with white a little bit
don't want to play the names of all of
the time and yeah this looks kind of
normal black has the bishop pair for but
a slightly cramped structure I'm getting
in for very likely he can play d 5 but I
don't know how good this hanging pawns
um yeah this is not a good hanging pawn
structure in my book but we're going to
see what happens I am maybe night a six
and that is true actually it's true
hmm ok that's I did not really think
about this so much Nyjah for maybe we
should be 744 he finds writer Bishop
Jake's yeah he for must be right
exploiting my trying to exploit my
better development in this position and
his offside night and week 6 square
maybe Bishop takes d5 maybe the critical
continuation not sure there should be
five de five deform maybe I a night be
five then not be 5c 596 that's
interesting we can we get an interesting
position as usual rook e8 set a move
maybe I have f4 maybe I have f4 then hmm
not so you need this position for black
yeah taking mmm yeah night cheeks is
threatening Knight f6 mmm if i take now
Queen takes 97 wins the exchange so I'm
going to check that's a really big Fork
where do i check on here oh wait i can
take on on b7 actually this is maybe the
the best way as the night is hanging
queen f neg let's take here first that's
that's best
and how do I really how do I actually
play this in the most forceful way it
looks he's kind of uncoordinated I up
here this one this is good double
attacking the knight and h7 if i get to
age seven this is going to be really
strong his king is not getting a lack
yeah his king is not getting any any
safe square so this was a nice nice win
out of the opening not due to knowledge
but somehow I mean sometimes you just
know something better but somehow I
think b5 is I don't know about this move
it looks this looks tricky to me looks
tricky to play huh but I know and
whether we're the mistake boss actually
he is certainly can play something like
60 on maybe rookie a door this kind of
thing light a cig so I went a form and
he has to play differently yeah okay the
computer actually says that this is good
for black huh that is that is surprising
me really why is it good for black I was
thinking about this move oh hmm now now
simply I did not considered as a black
has d 3 year I did not think about this
move at all and probably he also didn't
this is just just very strong the poor
Nia can be supported by the night and
now the night on b5 doesn't have any
useful yeah useful square you know I
mean I was only thinking about this
after which I am happily going here it's
not a clear position here that no I mean
I have four and he might have f 6 and so
on it's very complicated but this is all
mood this is just very strong yeah now i
can never that the night has no point it
has to go back
and in this situation I even have
trouble keeping this him for example if
I play a 4 here just to get it straight
he might play something like that and
this is not even possible so that was
the point hmm he is before it's not
really great and the thing is probably
if he is not doing that he will be in
some kind of trouble I think he after
that it's already a bit awkward because
what are you doing now I'm threatening
Knight f6 Bishop e7 there is no
convenient way to play that the comp
ones to take which is okay quite nice
for wide it's not the end of the world
rugby aid is still playable okay this is
probably not playable yeah and now I
played I think I hope in the most
precise way first taking here is good
because the the night is saying he
cannot do this this is a piece down so
this was the only move takes yeah I now
Queen takes or King test after King
takes Queen d3 is the decisive factor I
was looking for a moment because in this
position it's not that it's just an it's
an exchange of course but this is
unprotected this is unprotected and this
is unprotected and this is the key point
this double attack on two of the
unprotected units that same wins this
pawn and now rupee one queen age eight
is the big issue Black has snow he has
nothing it's got the exchange down and
white has this kind of mating attack
yeah that was a nice win yeah but a
little bit loose a bit em loose but
lucky because I we both did not see
correctly that like I can take and lady
for ya can I do something else by the
way you still can play if i go here
let's say i can still play that that's
kind of oops
kind of funny and this is also on now I
totally did not see that the pawn can
advance further okay thanks for watching